ce qui est
pour les cuisiner alexa mcdonough avait
plusieurs surnoms dont tout simplement
alexa elle était au delà de la
partisanerie une femme politique proche
des gens se rappellent son ancien
collègue et ancien député fédéral
néodémocrate pour acadie bathurst yvon
godin sa personne n'était personne
vraiment écouté la
respectable a travaillé fort comme je
vous dis pas ça pour les 2 min pour les
saisonniers que l'égalité de la femme
pour les sans abri de tout ce personnel
est une dame la considère comme une
grande dame alexa mcdonough est devenu
chef du nouveau parti démocratique de la
nouvelle écosse en 1980 un haut fait
d'armes à une époque où les femmes
étaient plus nombreuses à l'assemblée
législative au point par exemple où il
n'y avait même pas de toilettes pour les
femmes en politique les femmes s'étaient
pas c'était pas facile a été chef du
parti npd en numérique hausse pour une
dizaine d'années quand elle arrive à
ottawa c'était la grosse vache il
n'était pas facile
alexa mcdonough est devenu chef du
nouveau parti démocratique du canada en
pour être ensuite élu député en 1997
elle a tenu les rênes du parti jusqu'en
2003 elle est toujours demeuré très
proche des causes de justice sociale
qu'il a épousée avant d'entrer en
politique
arrêtez travail social donc à prix très
fiers les défis des dp fans alexa
mcdonough a eu une grande influence sur
de nombreuses personnes qui se sont
lancé en politique comme il a la chance
puis elle était très encourageante au
courage et le chef du npd jack médecine
écrit qu'elle a consacré sa vie à la
justice sociale a défendu les femmes en
politique et n'a jamais reculé devant le
défi son ancienne attachée de presse
karl bélanger lui a également rendu
hommage à nous avant
moi le défi qui leur a constamment dû
affronter était sa maîtrise du français
aurait voulu amener le parti encore plus
loin ça m'empêche pour bien des néo
démocrates et leur a jeté les bases qui
allait mener à la fameuse vague orange
de jack layton qui a déferlé sur le
canada ici c'était pas ni blanchet radio
canada à halifax